oh man I'm trying to think do you like
Paranormal Activity no no I I watched
the first paranormal activity on a plane
you know that's the best one right the
first one out of like the seven that's
the best one I guess so like I found
Sydney watched all seven yes I fell
asleep in like 20 minutes you should
watch some of the other ones wow they're
very funny oh really they're really fun
like look I get the whole thing of like
oh it was you know it was a really low
budget film and Steven Spielberg liked
it so we greenlit it and blah blah blah
but like I'm just like bro I'm just like
live leak is scarier than this [__] like
it's just [__] yeah
I don't know like I think the problem
with Paranormal Activity was that like
it was trying to sell you on like the
realistic aspect but it's like okay I
get it you know using the security
camera footage and all that kind of [__]
but it's like if I know it's a movie
yeah then it's just like eventually less
scary yeah the scariest thing about like
The Blair Witch was you know back in the
day before the internet there was you
know there were rumors around that this
wasn't actually a movie yeah but it was
actually just real fun footage and I
feel like having that Mystique to it
that's what made it scary because if you
actually watched The Blair Witch knowing
that it's a film I think it's a lot less
scary knowing that you know this is a
film that was produced and filmed and
scripted rather than oh my God we just
found like a tape and we don't know what
it is you know and we're gonna put it in
the cinemas anyway yeah I I feel like
that must yeah you know you know what
don't give it to the police look we were
a lot Dumber back then okay a lot of the
Mystique has gone thanks to the internet
now but you might not remember this but
you know as you know when growing up in
the before the edge of the internet
things like this could exist like I
remember what was it like Cannibal
Holocaust or something oh yeah like
didn't like the director of that get
arrested because people actually thought
it was real it was actually [__] real
yeah and you know I'd heard that there
were some horrendous things happening on
set of that film anyway but you know it
wasn't a snuff film yeah yeah exactly
thankfully enough I would actually say
that like as much as I don't like horror
films B grade horror films uh so [__]
fun to watch because it's like
immediately just from the scuffed nature
of it it just becomes more satirical and
actually in a lot of ways actually it's
really entertaining and funny the best B
grade horror film I ever watched was do
you know this movie called Dead Sushi no
no what is that so it was it was made by
this guy called takashimike who's like
the most like
okay he's like the most infamous
Japanese director
um but it's one of his he made like a
[__] load of B grade horror films but
it's 11 pretty [__] up and a lot of
them are [__] up yeah uh I think he
actually used to like direct porn before
he did that which is hilarious but like
that's one of the ones uh that Aki
showed me it's essentially just this
like story of I'm trying to remember
because it's been a while but it's
essentially like there's this like
female lead who is uh you know goes to
like a sushi establishment because she
wants to like learn the craft of like
you know making sushi and stuff like
that yeah and I think something along
the lines of like some like radioactive
waste uh spills onto some sushi and then
the sushi come alive and start killing
people they're a sausage party but
generally yeah basically and it's like
it's basically these like this sushi but
like they grow teeth and [__] and
they're just like and they just [__]
fly through the air and kill people it's
so Jank and but it's so hilarious and
entertaining and like there's a couple
of scenes where it's like genuinely
unnerving because it's a meme film right
like he gets really gory with these
films
um I think he was the one that made um
what is it audition that like really
[__] up like yeah like film yeah that
was probably his most famous yeah that's
his most famous one but like it's it's
not as bad as that one but um yeah he
basically was just like what would
happen if Sushi came back soon
yeah and then I'll make audition as well
it's one of those [__] up films ever
made tour of this I unlocked the core
memory yeah I was like I remember I
talked to Sydney about horror film and I
think me and uh you're ready to Alan had
watched uh
a horror movie together on Netflix and
we both thought it was like really
[__] stupid and funny and then Sydney
was talking about it like a month later
I was like yeah it's actually the like
this is one of my favorite horror films
of all time it's amazing and I just you
know it tells him and I was like oh oh
we watched that differently yeah it was
called uh cam
it's a horror film came out on Netflix
five years ago and um it was about like
a cam girl but I think the cam girl goes
like I can't remember oh I remember her
talking about like the cam girl goes
live and she's seeing herself go live as
the cam girl yeah yeah yeah and I can't
remember
every Eagles was not available
in a live stream live broadcast I don't
know if it's this one I'm reading the
plot I'm like what the [__] it's
probably this one right it is that one
yeah yeah that's crazy look at the
difference between the IMDb and the
Rotten Tomatoes IMDb 5.9 out of 10
Rotten Tomatoes 93 oh that's uh I can
see which Camp Sydney's in there she's
in the wrong Tomatoes count I just
thought that like I watched it and I
remember thinking like I feel like it's
kind of a cool idea but also I remember
the acting was like really bad yeah and
I was like
well I don't know if it's bad but it was
just like I don't know that's definitely
the killer for me with a lot of horror
films where it's like I I hear a lot of
synopsis for a lot of horror films and
I'm like that's an interesting premise
yeah but the problem is at least most of
the ones I've seen the execution the
execution is just so yeah [__] like
it's it's like the acting is and again
like that's why like hereditary was so
scary because Tony Collette was such a
good actress in that you know you can
get around that huh YouTube summary
actually unlocking another memory you
know maybe I watched that I thought was
actually pretty good or like it was kind
of funnily good but the Invisible Man
have you seen this one oh yeah yeah I've
heard of that one he literally just
terrorizes people with it it's like
YouTube prank gone wrong times a hundred
I think you could right it was good it
was good I think it's good yeah I think
I remember I liked it and I thought that
it was good like I'm trying to remember
if I liked it yeah no no it was good it
was good uh it was like actually intense
yeah because the whole point of the
tension right right so let me frame the
film from the beginning okay uh so this
girl I believe dated like a super super
smart guy right and uh
she breaks up with him and I believe
that you know the breakup wasn't going
didn't go well but for one reason or
another she's really really scared of
this person right and then weird things
start happening in her life and it's to
the point where she thinks that uh
either like a ghost is [__] with her
or someone else is [__] with her life
to the point where her life just goes
just spirals downwards and she is
convinced that her ex has something to
do with it and people are like no you're
[__] crazy you're [__] crazy and
and we don't and we don't know what is
really going on behind the scenes until
it gets revealed right and uh that's
that spoiler territory uh but the name
of the movie gives it away yeah I feel
yeah
it's called The Invisible Man yeah is it
actually yeah it's called The Invisible
Man perhaps the one the culprit is in
the title but I but I felt like the the
way that like why that movie was good at
least for my memory again this is years
ago was that it was like it felt
helpless yeah because this guy's so op
yeah yeah because oh no I just I just
remembered why it was it was called that
because her ex is dead
what a great movie but again like that's
that that also like further proves my
point of why like a lot of again
Japanese horror is good it's because
it's like again that idea of
helplessness yeah right like in like the
garage and like the ring and like One
Missed Call is a [__] terrifying film
the Japanese one the American one is
[__] they like completely botched that
one but the Japanese one is like
genuinely terrifying man it's again it's
because of this idea of like the the
unknown right yeah I don't know what the
[__] is terrorizing my life and killing
me and killing all of my friends yeah
I'm gonna get to the bottom of it and
then we're gonna [__] around and find
out what about if like somebody was an
invisible man and all they did was cut
your nails perfectly every single night
in your sleep and you wake up in the
nails
you know they're there every night you
ever had that feeling have you ever had
that feeling where it's just like I
don't know something you wake up one day
and just something in your room or
something is just off and you don't know
if you just have [__] memory or if like
something is like all your partner is
terrorized yeah I mean I'm currently in
that phase again where I'm falling
asleep to listening to like cave stories
I don't know why because yeah it's been
a few months so they've made more videos
there's people who talk about it and
every time I go to bed now and I'm
listening to that like someone's dying
in a cave I'm like did I lock the door
hopefully I locked the door why are you
listening to that before you go to bed I
don't know it's like these guys because
all the horror channels like Credit
World credits do they're so monotone
right yeah they're never like hyped up
about like they're not like [__]
YouTubers yeah you will not believe what
happened in this cave it's always like
in this cave on January 14th oh yeah two
kids went in and one guy came out this
is the story about The Deadly cave
known as the the flocky wacky cave
I'll tell you what I've been listening
while falling into a sleep recently it's
uh yeah I've been listening to I guess
science and uh physics videos yeah all
the time and I this is one this is gonna
sound so bad right it's gonna sound so
bad because there's this one YouTube
channel I think it's called history of
the universe where he breaks down some
like Concepts to do with physics uh and
and uh puts like a really really
interesting story into it and gives like
really interesting metaphors and
basically goes through the entire
history about how this discovery was
made and how we came to discover let's
say our perception of how time works can
we time travel backwards and forwards he
basically goes through everything
um and it's super super interesting
because a lot of times so many sort of
physics yeah it's kind of like something
you know you actually you actually uh
just you actually uh said it perfectly
it's like basically the summoning salt
of physics because I've heard a lot of
gold split because a lot a lot of stuff
and then Kepler came in
and so we're gonna clip through time
right now we're gonna go to the fourth
dimension
um yeah and uh because a lot of stuff
that he talks about I already know
because I'm I'm super interested in this
stuff anyway but the way he portrays the
information is just super super
interesting and for some reason helps me
get to sleep like that I discovered him
when we were touring America and for
some reason whenever I put a video on
and his all of his videos are like at
least 50 minutes minimum right and 50
50. so it's like 50. really yeah yeah
literally the summoning salt of physics
right and I I'm I just like for some
reason his voice is so calming that I
get invested in his story and then about
20 minutes in I'm just like conked out I
wake up this entire playlist is just
done right and so every turn up knowing
one fifth of the physics yeah yeah so
every time he releases a new video it
takes me about three weeks to get
through it because I'm like I started
falling asleep I keep falling asleep I'm
like [__] this was such an I want to
know how this video ends I need to I
like I need to see the entire video
because it's a super interesting story I
get invested and then even though I'm
invested I fall asleep so I'm like this
is a night this is a night yeah I've had
that so often with like falling asleep
to like veritasium videos or like yeah
videos it's just like it's it's the tone
at which they talk at yeah and the kind
of slow pacing in nature and like you
know it's obviously just like the lack
of like [__] YouTube sound effects
and [__] yeah yeah yeah where it's like
oh this is just like it's nice it's just
it's like someone's just talking to me
and just yeah asleep yeah yeah I don't
know what it is something about here
hearing people talk about just like
physics Concepts or just like because
there's no there's no volume change yeah
no no watch one of my videos it's just
like bro it looks like a [__] seismic
seismic yeah you can't like you can't
tell